heute zeigen wir euch einige gestiken
und mimiken die in deutschland häufig
benutzt werden einige von diesen kennt
ihr vielleicht schon andere sind
vielleicht neu los gehts
ja
nein
klingt gut
machen wir so
hallo
danke für mich nicht
ich drücke dir die daumen
keine ahnung
das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein
was soll das denn
bist du bescheuert
du hast ja einen vogel
[Musik]
wenn ihr neu in deutschland seiten müsst
ihr nicht nur einige neue gesten und
mimiken kennenlernen ihr müsst
wahrscheinlich auch einige neue deutsche
vokabeln lernen und dafür empfehlen wir
euch unsere partner app sie längst lang
ist verfügbar im googleplex tor und auch
im app store von apple
und dort findet ihr unter anderem einen
vokabeltrainer mit diesem vokabeltrainer
könnt ihr die 6.000 wichtigsten
deutschen vokabellernen die ihr braucht
um das b2 level zu erreichen also um
einigermaßen euch auf deutsch ausdrücken
zu können und dort gibt es viele
verschiedene übungen mit beispielsätzen
probiert die app mal aus hier unten ist
der link und hier oben auch
sehr gut
lecker
lasst uns einen trinken
das war ein scherz
ab morgen ist schluss mit ihm für immer
ich bin mir nicht sicher
ich lüge
ich beobachte dich
ich bin entsetzt weil sich jemand nicht
an die regeln hält
[Musik]
besonders populär ist auch der
zeigefinger als zeichen der ermahnung
vor allem von eltern an ihre kinder
du du du du
auch in deutschland benutzt man den
mittelfinger ein sehr internationales
zeichen in deutschland bedeutet er
eigentlich das gleiche wie überall er
ist nicht besonders nett
ein weiteres zeichen typisch für
deutschland ist das klopfen in der uni
zum beispiel hört ihr manchmal das
klopfen auf den tischen statt einem
klatschen und in deutschland ist das
manchmal üblicher und auch höflicher
dass man nach einem vortrag klopft talk
talk talk talk talk und das war mein
vortrag über dem sinn des lebens
ein weiterer moment wo man das klopfen
benutzt ist wenn man eine größere gruppe
menschen begrüßt zum beispiel kommst du
in ein restaurant und dort sitzen zehn
menschen und man möchte nicht einzeln
jedem die hand schütteln also macht man
klopf klopf klopf auf den tisch und sagt
hallo in die runde
kennt ihr noch andere gesten und mimiken
die euch in deutschland begegnet sind
oder habt ihr vielleicht eine lustige
geschichte wo euch jemand etwas gezeigt
hat oder es vielleicht sogar zu einem
missverständnis kam wir freuen uns auf
eure geschichten postet die mal hier
unten in den kommentaren und jetzt
freuen wir uns wenn wir uns auch am
sonntag wieder sehen zu unserem nächsten
video tschüss bis bald